let's let's jump away from the funny
celebrity stuff into the depressing
distressing civil war all right great we
got the story from the washington times
distressingly high level of support for
assassinating politicians among young
democratic men i saw this headline and i
went what what is that no way and then i
looked at the data
and the numbers are comparable to
republican women
i was like
why is it that
maybe there's something about i i don't
know because young democrat women
uh and young republican men are about
one-third in favor of political
assassination and i'm like yo that's bad
enough yeah that they're right yeah so i
love how they framed this like young
democratic men are in favor and then
it's like 44 said they would uh they
support assassination and young
republican women at 40 percent
and then i was like okay so let me
actually i don't know if if this will
actually work if i can pull up here we
go
it's the southern poverty law center who
i don't trust and is probably wrong
but um
reading through this
the fact that they would list young
democratic men as the most in support of
this political violence i was like
well why would the splc
deride their own donors
you know like
they make their bread their bread and
butter is young democrats so maybe it's
legit and i gotta be honest a lot of
what they say i think it sounds
absolutely plausible there's a there's a
bunch in this server that they produced
notably about feminism about uh great
replacement things like that we'll talk
about the feminism stuff in a minute
because this is that's also fascinating
but you do the
partisanship and violence part
take a look at this
total approval for assassinating a
politician who is harming the country or
our democracy
44 of younger democratic amendments
that's 50 50 years old oh that's less
than 50 years old
approve
54
disapprove
among young republican men it's 34
approval to 57 percent disapproval
there's a
decent amount of
young republican men who just don't know
but look at this younger republican
women is 40 to 55. that's four percent
off from the democrats and then younger
democratic women is 32 approved you know
i don't care if it's 44. you take a look
at the boomers and the gen xers
and the support is
under double digits right
among older democrat women nine percent
older republican women ten percent older
democrat men six percent and older
republican men six percent
when the boomer generation passes on
the dominant power in society is going
to be overwhelmingly in favor of
assassinating political opponents i
think that these numbers though show
youthful ignorance because as you get
older you realize that violence you
start to realize things about the way
the world works and that you can't just
destroy the thing you hate and expect
everything to be okay
we're talking about 45 year olds ian um
did you get the 45 year olds count as
younger did you get how young was that
that's a problem
how many people they pulled like did
they pulled six thousand fifteen hundred
fifteen hundred people so it's not that
many people too it depends on who they
were pulling the kids might have been on
prozac uh well playing a lot of video
games look i think the bigger issue is
that the southern poverty law center
needs to keep people scared so they can
make money off of them oh right yeah so
that's the first thing they say their
methodology is from april 18th 25th 2022
tolchen research conducted a nationwide
survey of 1500 adults ages 18 plus it
was conducted via online panel the
margin of error for the full 1500 sample
is plus or minus 2.53 percent
maybe well
it's bad timing because i think it was
yesterday the man who attempted to
assassinate reagan was led out of jail
hinckley john hinckley jr yes and they
said we should think he's
doing okay that's what they said we
think he's going to do it you guys ready
for this next part oh my gosh check this
out i'm scared in
another poll total approval for
threatening a politician who is harming
the country democracy
younger republican men 46 percent
approve
of threatening threatening a politician
52 disapprove but only 44 actually
approve of assassination if that means
republicans i'm sorry i'm sorry it's uh
34 of republican men approve that means
you've got about 12 percent all bark no
bite yeah they're gonna they're going to
shake their fist at the politician and
then do nothing but it's the inverse for
younger democrat men
40 are okay with threats 44 with
assassination that means that four
percent doesn't want to give you a
warning
they're not going to tell you what they
intend to do now here's the best here's
the funny part the same thing is true of
younger republican women 31 agree with
threats but 40 agree with assassination
these young republican women don't want
to warn you before they
yeah personally who in the right mind
would tell a poll that they want they're
in favor of assassinating politicians
that's insane you're gonna be put on a
watch list instantly if you tell someone
that i would imagine good point ian
which suggests the number is probably
much higher and secondly
uh i had a point i'll come back to it i
don't know what the what the [ __ ] look
at this total approval of for
participating in a political revolution
the the here
this is fascinating
the one group that is most in favor of
of participating in a revolution is
young republican men i tweeted out 45
i'm getting really tired of this alien
versus villain narrative that we're
going through right now what i mean is
like the weird hero like the young
transgender kid that feels like an alien
in the reality or superman who's an
alien or like a superhero that's not
normal this non-normal hero versus a
blanket form of evil because when you
think there are things out there that
are evil then you may be willing to
destroy them and it's making people
think that killing is the way to solve
things and it's not so
it's a fantasy marvel superhero movies
are fantasy there are no good and evil
thing like it's black and white actually
not black and white
put them in jail event
avengers infinity war did a really good
job of a job of addressing this
they you know thanos was driven by his
character arc was literally i'm going
i'm doing good right
he and and you actually have that
conversation in the film with captain
america when he's like we don't trade
lives versus thanos being like i'm gonna
save the universe
thanos thought he was the good guy and
so uh there i watched this really
amazing
uh uh critique filmmaker's critique of
infinity war and they said what people
didn't realize is that it's a hero's
journey story same as any other story
but it's about thanos yeah dude to have
the comic right here this is where it
all came from if it's called the
infinity gauntlet and you're right tim
you explained it exactly thanos was
stannis was an anomaly he was he was nor
you know from depends on the perspective
you look at thanos from is whether or
not he's evil
yeah he is
it really works though when they set up
somebody to be just pure evil
i mean i fell for it i was i was i was
listening to npr
you know
two years ago watching cnn literally i
was i was brainwashed because you go
with their evil so it doesn't matter
what we do i probably would have been
you know if they gave away free coffee
or something i would have filled that
out i would have been another
point for the democrats yeah so so what
happened for you how did you one day not
like how do you break out from oh yeah
am i coming out my walk away yeah you're
walking away well i talk i talk to
brandon a lot because we're we're you
know it's this is what's so funny is me
and a guy like brandon we never would
have talked that's brandon strzok yeah
yeah yeah we we they're bringing all
these people together that would have
never associated with each other and and
so it's kind of bizarre but uh it
started with the uh with the the white
shaming stuff you know that that was it
it was like take a seat give up your job
sorry we're not hiring white people
we're full with white people at comedy
clubs we're not casting white people and
then slowly i'm like am i supposed to
just give up my life
and they would say yes take a look at
this as part of the same poll the great
replacement they say as you know the
demographic makeup of america is
changing and becoming more diverse with
the us census estimating white people
will be a minority in approximately 25
years generally speaking do you find
these changes to be very positive
somewhat positive somewhat negative or
very negative you know what's funny
what do we have we have 63 percent of
democrats say either somewhat or very
positive and i'm like
there is something deeply wrong with you
if you're like it's a good thing that a
racial group is is being diminished or
whatever now for the people that view it
negatively i have some questions about
why they view it negatively sure but
it's not as bad as people view it pop
positively you know what i mean like if
you're like hey it's kind of a bad thing
that a group of people is slowly
disappearing or whatever i'll be like
okay well let's talk about that
for the democrats they're like this is
good i'm kind of like yeah that's kind
of creepy and racist that's weird well
even the white politicians they're like
yeah we'll be gone yeah that's weird
it harkens back to like that they're
trying to they're worried too much about
the skin color and not the not the
ideology of the roma i'm gonna keep
talking about romans it's awesome but
like this roman supremacy thing where
like you know it was started by slaves
slave masters they try and like even i
mean i'm i'm i don't want to hate on the
catholic church
but i do hate on the catholic church
because i can't stand the organization
of power and that you have to have this
authority of a pope that you've got to
go through that's authoritarian if you
want to communicate with god it's within
you is that a pedophile you got to go
through the pope no unfortunately yeah
and it was hilarious pretty good
my thing on the the great replacement
stuff is
you know democrats have talked about
demographic changes and means of
maintaining political power
tucker carlson then mentions they talk
about it then they accuse him of
far-right white supremacist conspiracy
theories and i'm like dude they're
outright telling the splc they they're
they viewed positively that white people
are becoming a minority i'm like
race shouldn't matter
you know what's funny is this survey
didn't have a doesn't matter option
it's like is it good or bad yeah or do
you not know and i'm like it's not good
or bad this is what it is if that's
what's happening you know i don't know
mixing and mingling it's you know right
right i think it's good for immune
systems to racial diversity is good for
the immune system i believe it is but
ultimately what matters to me is the
values i'm going to put that on my
tinder profile there you go
values matter meritocracy individual
uh freedoms
personal freedom personal liberty uh
meritocracy i say that uh personal
responsibility there we go that's one
yeah those are things the responsibility
yeah freedom of speech
the um safety and security and your
person and your property you know the
right to self-defense due process
constitutional rights
the fascinating thing is
they say in this let me see if i can
pull it up
they say
if we hope to secure a multi-racial
democracy and prevent partisan violence
uh our results show this is that a
substantial effort on the part of
activists institutions and government
will be required if we hope to secure a
multi-racial democracy
fascinating
stephen marsh was on this show and he's
the guy who wrote the book the next
civil war which i reference fairly often
and he said within the united states
there is a multicultural democracy in a
constitutional republic he said he
favored multicultural democracy i said i
favor constitutional republic
and i think he's right i think that is
the split the splc is very much on the
side of they say multi-racial democracy
but democracy is the real point here
we're not a democracy we have some
democratic institutions like we elect
our representatives but we don't and we
have referendums but for the most part
our government is run by elected
representatives who
represent us
i like the constitution
i like the fact that there is like a set
of rules and understandings as to what
the government can and can't do they
want to get rid of that yeah what they
want is majoritarian rule
whatever we say goes which i think is
nightmarish the splc outright says they
want to secure that
it's never been more clear in my opinion
well they're going after
equity we
equality is is out you don't even hear
the word equality anymore you only hear
equity which is forced outcome and
nobody knows what that means no one even
realizes that's what's happening
um
right and so you can't you would never
watch a football game if you knew the
score and that's what's happening that's
why people aren't watching netflix
because they know the score they know
the story they know it's going to be
this type of person this type of person
this view this view this view and
there's no surprise anymore because it's
not but tella tell it to us again but
this time as trump
well maybe i'll do it as jordan peterson
it's like it's like no one knows about
equity tim it's like personal
responsibility
clean your room eat a lobster yeah now
cry cry you must read a tear
it's like you got to stop doing cocaine
off a stripper's butt it's like call you
crying i don't even know how he came up
with that it's like a miracle tim even
came up with that see i can't be the
executive director sheamus is going to
regret not being yeah she was here it
would have been great because we could
have this is my snl audition because i
can't get one so i hope they're watching
yeah we could have had jordan peterson
debate ben shapiro yeah that would have
been fun
terrific yeah i think you made a good
point tyler about equity and about
equality of outcome which is basically
what equity is that they will kneecap
well i knew i'd have that outcome it's
like i said it so in a game of football
if the per the team that was leading no
longer got the ball until they until the
other team scored and got there no one
will watch that sport no one's watching
you can't even call it a sport at that
point it's because they're not able to
compete evenly this is and this is
poisoning every industry because i i
mean i talk about this a lot you know on
social media and stuff and and uh i'm
sure we'll talk about the lawsuit in a
bit but people reach out to me and every
single department of every job this is
poisoning and people are quitting
they're because they're like i don't
want to be a part of this people are
managers are being forced to hire people
based on skin color and they're put in
this really
really tough situation you know
and uh and people people are just
it's
up i'll be honest right running a
company
there there are weird laws that you're
looking at and california's got it crazy
like they mandate on the board certain
like you have to have x amount of women
or something like that
so then
your company is no longer built by those
who are good at the job it's built by
people who fit quotas yeah it is
interesting i think men and women is the
best example of the value of diversity
because i
when i have conversations with people i
find that having a woman in with the
conversation is a very different kind of
communication not always but there's
logic which is a very male thing then
there's emotions which is a very
feminine thing maybe and um but when it
comes to race like i'm interested in
hearing people's backgrounds and these
other cultures maybe they're from
another country
i think it's way less
important i don't know when it comes to
diversity hiring women like i'm glad
you're here lydia i like that to hear
your perspective oh do we have a female
oh i didn't see lydia i didn't know they
put her on the screen all the time
is that offensive of me to say lydia no
that i'm in the corner no no just that
there's a value
a value of like male and female
diversity
absolutely right and we know that women
like people this is why women do jobs
like these school teachers and nurses
and men are engineers turns out
engineering earns more money because
it's more precise and even men when they
go into nursing they go into nurse
anesthesia which is it turns your
patient into an object because they're
completely asleep and then the men take
over exactly yeah that's what earns the
most money yeah it's the engineering but
you're entirely correct ian yeah there
is a lot of value there especially
between men and women and what different
genders tend to offer but however you
have to understand that there are
there's an equal distribution of
incompetence i think across genders and
once you factor in race i i it becomes
very strange but i do think there are
some value to men women ratio generally
speaking i got an idea yeah it's a
stupid idea but i think it's worth
filming yes starting a new company
and intentionally having the corporate
ethos anti-meritocracy
so we part we intentionally hire the
people who seem to be the worst at the
job
and maybe that's next we'll pull like a
george costanza and make like the best
company ever yeah oh my god i love that
opposite do the opposite i'm pretty sure
like we'd start a sandwich shop and we'd
hire all the people with no experience
no drive and it just burned down just
call it good looking
company
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there